what I waited hey house to go into
broach my name is Mira
yeah okay I've got a really low girl
god damnit these compilations don't I
don't have much time today so I'm
recording extremely early just so that I
can have a video out today I once called
you friend
new kids hey you want to take a selfie
just for kunst Oh Graham okay I forgot
what we were doing enter the genetics
lab is that here no it's far away okay
we must journey oh god damn it why don't
have to start it like this this is a
terrible start I'm sorry okay alright
okay this could be our last episode I
know it's been quite a journey thank you
for following with me this far
but we're gonna end it god damn it if it
last thing I'll give it up should not
talk like that I don't think anyone
records this early all the youtubers all
was so up so late aren't they I'm doing
it wrong doing it wrong as a youtuber
where's the goddamn I walked the wrong
way here we are okay
oh no this is where the Happy Tree
Friends kind of guys are the Satanist
animals or whatever remember that
episode I'm man bear I mean we think of
the first game the first game it's so
good they improved some stuff for this
one but what just to be extra spooky
tonight
I remember that super old episode 6
hours and we're good to go
for real hahahahaha no we're gonna use
the kite thing okay cool shut up Scott
what does okay bring snacks or anything
yeah we should snacks the genetic one
it's one of the first season's episode I
think I had those episodes on VHS so
good you know
ah ash ash everything that could enhance
your ability could possibly make three
men quickly quickly
you see that AC fan over there yeah I
was already scanning it over by the gate
on the left side can't miss it on the
left side if you've bought into that
fair the oscillation of the gas will
filter it through the expansion valve
mixing it with the pressurized
refrigerant inside the condenser course
Wow of course how could I have been so
blind that makes any sense kid I'll fire
the Hat okay
don't need to stand closer maybe we
switched from daytime to nighttime
that's our last ability cool we did it
you guys all right here okay oh this is
creepy I like it
they did the Michael Jackson dance in
the end of it too
it's so cool reliving my childhood man
some young people interested in genetic
engineering huh
wonderful please come in oh hello
oh there's more okay my my there's a lot
of you oh wow okay interested in genetic
engineering genetic science began as a
simple question can a monkey be made to
have four asses instead of one that's
how it started the answer was yes and
now we've been able to give more asses
to pigs horses everything you can
imagine oh my god can I have another ass
oh you're one of the cynics huh well
meet me over here for the tour and I'll
show you how come on don't be shy we
don't want to miss the forest gorillas
feeding yes of course the four hour the
four s gorillas please have a seat
you ever play that video game - okay
it's just like this yet here you can see
our greenhouse genetic engineering is
helpful to grow larger tomatoes onions
cucumbers and vegetable here I'll have
less means more nutrition for people all
around the planet what good did that do
huh you bible-thumpers are all alike
don't play God you'll pay for it let's
continue up to the second
I think this guy is an ass man I don't
know course it's combining animals like
these donkey Apes bunny fish squirrel
donkeys is more once we put more asses
on these we will truly be benefiting
science finally science at all what's
your name little boy super Greg his cane
hasn't bought on a once we know how to
do things to animals we can hopefully
apply them to mankind you think having
more asses is impossible I tell you it's
not you see genetic engineering is not
just for animals and veggies we are
working towards helping people as well
here you can see genetic mutations of my
dead son most people don't remember that
I once had a young child named Terrance
I remember I was Terrence was killed
tragically in town when some kids were
playing around with a relic belonging to
Barbara Streisand was doing this all as
a way to bring back your dead son bring
him back well of course not
I'm trying to give his dead body more
asses so he can finally rest in peace
now let's continue on to the fourth well
here we are the top floor of the
building and the end of our tour what it
ease these horrible monstrous mistakes
of science our new benefactor has asked
that we genetically alter some of the
local sixth graders and make them
stronger and crazier okay okay
why the [ __ ] would you do that how do
you mean why the [ __ ] would you make
genetically enhanced sixth graders calm
down super Craig how do you think we pay
for all this we have financial donors
our latest benefactor has asked for this
army of mutated sixth graders to protect
his altered cats
oh no altered cats oh right over this
way oh my oh my with more our company
can add asses to things at very
competitive rates the problem is that
cats seem to become really aggressive
when driven more
they've proven to be quite deadly then
why would you break a bunch of kids up
here look there's nothing to worry about
this entire facility has a very complex
security that's never happened before
[Music]
mr. Connor if you shut down the security
grid then everyone in this building is
going to die oh my god the cage breach
[Music]
that's a lot of ads many ask cats
everyone great can't wait to fight the
many asshats that's that's just what
this game was missing I don't know
they're all gonna move in now Jesus but
they are not this is a not a good place
to start I guess confused
this broken fairy of the face that's how
you got it oh my god another Peter PI
reference please stop guys come back
captain diabetes very nice yeah was that
a hairball yeah well these are pretty
easy to kill let's beat the [ __ ] of them
okay yeah it should be Z what is he
doing in the background I like the logo
over there company by that way so good
let's just use call garlis out a outro
bolt sorry the program man
uh how about that beautiful it's really
good look at that beautiful almost all
dead let's finish them up nicely now
please not more son of the cat but no
more uh damn it alright let's use this
one just cuz it's so goddamn cute and I
love it so much and it's fast
only LLC's take forever they're all
moments dead I mean come on if I but
can't probably you'll thank me in heaven
for letting me kill you there we go
punch it out of that cat thank you okay
we did it you're single Isis well we
have very strong answers hahahaha okay
I'm glad glad we did that yes we must
escape the laughs maybe maybe we can go
through some of the larger exhibits this
way children no let's not do that I love
their logo
they stole my logo didn't they but fee
loose this was definitely not supposed
to happen
it's okay we'll be safe in the tour trim
all the tour tram is offline somebody's
gonna have to get to the CPU and hit the
override switch where's the CPU down on
the third level it was silly to put it
there with me to the third level and
flip the switch oh wow
all right well it was obviously the
woods all right is it this way Oh Mac
down okay we can't go Oh Mouse Oh Mia
Mac
it must be the fart thing right yeah
sandblast this one let me pet it Meowth
catch them so I want to see this oh they
have been posting pictures I didn't
realize that's so funny he's so upset I
gotta check those of our update every go
love Craig so good I was in ok Bernie's
diabetes here no come on we definitely
mean diabetes captain diabetes of course
thank you let me just fart in your face
that's radioactive on it okay and then
we use a time fart just swish it back
around oh my god oh I can climb it
okay it all makes sense now we can reach
here right yes should be up here no it's
down there what in the world what a lot
of these huh
and now
[Music]
then we gotta use oh my god we gotta use
all our ability this is crazy now that
won't change anything will sit oh never
mind
I wasn't fast enough no actually I was
okay
then we got to use captain diabetes
again oh my god
what is happening why is it red I see
[Applause]
literally no one did
all right well I'm glad we did that
thank you very much captain diabetes
you're a hero of your people now we just
got to put this back here we truly are a
mastermind of puzzle solving Kenny I
give it up give it up this takes a lot
of skill to do what you just did and
good looks of course there we go please
just open now you can get down to the
third level thank you should be coming
to my dead son now
no no hey Jasper
get over here deep there's a picture of
some beads man it's I want to see some
boobs where well that was easy oh my god
oh it's panic what is that
Oh put it back oh sorry sorry bad day
should we attack these guys
[Music]
okay well at least we get the advantage
now this is really weird
the game was weird before but now are
they half cow for Ashes for sixth grader
Wow science truly have gotten so far we
can just instantly kill all these easy
oh no they're gonna explode the ass is
exploded oh okay that's cool they do
damage when they die as well
I'll wipe my assets with you for these
nice I like how their asses wiggle I
mean I just enjoy it it's funny to me
out yep
call girls get the number I feel like we
should kill the small ones right
I don't think daxing is this guy's first
problem right now let's use the old on
this funky I love it someone
it's so cute that's pretty stupid air ok
let's finish him just don't kill Craig
what no no you might think it's bad how
about that alright boom let's dance baby
all right we did it we killed that
monkey butts things isn't a weird have
monkeys have such weird but like how did
that happen
am i right am I the only one thinking
about this I was so waited out the first
time I saw a baboon but there's the boob
button
oh my god what are you doing
Connor brought me here Stephen catch
sick son of a [ __ ] you shut up King
soon this town will be rid of you and
all the [ __ ] friends
we're freedom outs badass we know what
you're doing Eric
putting cut you're in into people's
drugs and alcohol to make them crazy we
want to know why yeah why you sick [ __ ]
dude
do I really have to spell it out King
this city is sick we both know it
there's only one time of year when this
town is the way it should be on
Christmas so I joined the Chamber of
Commerce and use them to unleash my
master plan
Mitch Conners plans for success run for
mayor get tons of followers clone new
kid into genetic mutant win election
make everyday Christmas selfie oh I see
okay Emma that actually had a meaning
huh dude you've got too far this time
nobody's gonna let you be mayor
oh yeah I've got all the new kids
followers every last one of them is now
following me
gee that was smart Eric I know that
Christmas every day sounds like fun but
it really wouldn't be Becky dr. Timothy
if you guys don't mind I've got an
election to win
yeah oh there goes the main CPU darn it
why did I put that thing on a mobilise
trapdoor god this guy I'm afraid now
someone will have to go clear to the
ground level and call for the tour tram
from there Nami fine
hurry up new kid we gotta get out of
here yeah sorry I'm really sorry guys I
feel terrible for wasting your time your
precious time alright we're gonna use
this shiz again for some reason I don't
know why this is a thing it's kind of
lame like I said before usually they
have those these kind of things to
access new areas that you couldn't
before you do have it but it just seems
like a chore almost it's like okay I
guess I have to look another one and
another one
first of all let's figure out what we're
doing probably we can't use the hamster
here oh we can all right let's do it
chaos more like shove it up my butt
thank you I guess you got to keep the
game a certain amount of hours and it's
impossible to do unless you have some
sort of aspect like this so I mean to be
fair I get it it's like it's like it was
really funny the first time like they
all generally made me laugh but now I'm
like it's like hearing the same joke
almost saiga okay all right should we
fart wait why did I go down here I
missed it no it's right there
wait what in the world and look at that
diabetes we need diabetes everyone don't
we all need a little bit now without
damn but there's those muscles down
incredible for these suck hey guys uh
why don't we let me just buy some of
that please is there anything else
actually good we can buy you like when
your outfit thank you well
[Applause]
this is just like have fun wait what in
the world thanks for the tip really
really appreciate it okay so we got to
keep moving here god damn swear to God
they got beat headphones now that's
definitely the definition of smart
you're right oh my god there's more of
them
are you cereal right now gasps are you
cereal I'm asking seriously are you
cereal and it's gone it's gone everybody
there we go thank you thank you mean our
son konichiwa thanks to your support I
was able to pull through and look at
that would you look at that master we're
getting on the master level of things
everybody what is this nice very nice oh
oh this is when it's gonna get weird
is he gonna ask our mom you're not my
dad
alright how do we save him for real
it's gonna get weird it's gonna get
really weird real soon boys and girls
and ganas oh all right daddy it's not
that hard to get DNA okay okay but I
watched that episode of South Park
yesterday where Randy wants to have like
Native American DNA so that he feels
oppressed like it has something to be a
victim about those BOTS and jars am I
gonna have to pick like one urn I'm
actually gonna just cut off my dad's
head because all right well I'm sorry
you know how to do this that was it
that was his story the CPU is waiting
for either of our DNA just trigger mom
later what she just did get to DNA
sample from one of my parents all right
so I'm not this is like a choice where I
don't really care about either one of
them so it doesn't really matter
maybe both of them will die in the end
but let's do the classic thing that
we're doing Sweden when it doesn't see
Apes hats over there okay good I just
wanted to check okay
oh let do it don't kink yet learn it
cough cough a lonely link yeah Barney
Olli doula dot okay we're gonna pick our
dad okay okay let's try that again
[Music]
okay I guess that one
I can't talk to her
I can only tariff the arm so it is
selectable for them anyway can I just
want to take her arm bed let's play
along for now let's add let's see one
I'm trying to talk to her like right
that's what the goal is to talk to her
here right now this is kill both of them
[Music]
this is pretty messed up
now let's go and do the same here now I
wanted to kill him
now damn it
you did the right thing sweetheart Oh
get out of here and don't get help
we can't kill him bummer bye dad
all right buddy these are strong men
cloven heirloom nice thanks guy
phone destroy yeah oh my god it's a
sixth grader oh wow yeah listen up me oh
yeah chicks chicks like but if your
check yeah let me know if you like butts
or not you can still dance with the but
you can't work a multi perk I think we
ran out of butts didn't we all right
well I think we're done here
all right all right hey guys
yeah I was just having a good time
killing my parents
Carmen is doing I don't think so
gasps you came all this way just to die
[ __ ] and friends freedom pals Coonan
Frank's freedom pals
careful guys he's got some kind of super
weapon it's over fat ass we're gonna
tell everyone on you yeah you hear that
Connor sing tis it we need each other
don't you get it
I create the crime and you stomp it out
I am good for your franchise oh [ __ ] I
get it now but then the new kid had to
come along and try to stop me for good I
had no choice but to have my own new kid
built what have you done America simple
it's the same visit friend by creating a
massive genetically altered [ __ ] friend
from that heroes DNA
what dude that's so [ __ ] bass where
do you mean keen really you're just
gonna fight a superhero by creating a
big genetic mutant from the heroes DNA
that's like every douchebag superhero
movie that's like the ultimate enemy Oh
give me a break
well anyways I wasn't able to finish
getting the new kids DNA so I had to
resort to cloning a different superhero
which superhero
neighbor ah no way what Oh
[Music]
no that's like that most annoying thing
we could fly right now or I'll get a
migraine yeah that seems like his issue
right now is having a migraine all right
so we got another bus battle okay fair
enough all right okay of course
oh he moves in oh damn a lot of damage
and two at a time as well okay let's try
and make him confused probably won't
work but let's throw a shot his immune
oh my god he's so annoying
he just is so incredibly goddamn
annoying
captain diabetes moves in
he has a lot I have man can you attack
him from everywhere I know you can't oh
god I can't attack him from here are you
serious
well then we should give this
okay so he starts oh wow oh wow oh he
looks like the guy from Family Guy he
Peter Griffin
oh it's like a volcano oh yeah I forgot
how annoying is so cute super furry okay
we have the day-night thing there you go
that fart alright let's use the old
[Music]
and it's old time baby yuck yeah oh damn
that's a lot more damage nice I thought
I could take him on even though it was
daytime nighttime I get to attack twice
that must be a glitch we have to make it
night again
oh it's defense goes down yet of code
only last certain time I see [ __ ] give
me my old thing
here we go okay this makes all the
difference
[Music]
got it okay so now we turn into night
and day if I go back home with your
sunburn I won't hear the end of it from
I met it very night he looks so much
like Peter Griffin I suppose in Tanana
and now with super Craig oh [ __ ] we
don't have it [ __ ] hurry
damn I wonder if that did it
no come on you steal you steal you stay
out come on Oh
Hey
I don't know if I'm doing this right oh
my god this is the fart - in the mo one
fern
to rule the galaxy I'm so glad he said
that
I'm so glad finally a game recognizes
the power of one part I wonder how his
ass look like that was pretty amazing
dude I've never heard anyone maybe now
you have a new appreciation for what
genetic engineering has I want to get a
bite of your day maybe disinfect my
sheep by a I survived genetic mutants
t-shirt purchase a photo of you enjoying
the tour
Wow look at that lots of great things to
remember your visit let's get the [ __ ]
out of here
that was [ __ ] Thanks come on get a
t-shirt all right we gotta go tell on
carpet oh no what did it be Syrian who
the new kid farted so think he made it
next week what check your phones
it's farted so big he made it come on
freedom pass we have to stop him yeah
sorry sorry about that one guys I really
I really
sorry but how do they how do you go
through their classic challenge and okay
that's a weird one I think tomorrow is
probably gonna be the last episode gasps
but that was cool that was fun thank you
for joining me I can't wait to share the
last one with you it's been quite a
journey let's finish this thing tomorrow